plus de temps. Pourquoi?
Reportage et on n'en parle au
panel.
- Judith Farrell
et Christian Pepin veulent
rénover leur maison en entier
et y ajouter une mezzanine.
- C'est le salon qui va devenir
notre chambre principale.
- Mais pour ces résidents
d'Ahuntsic-Cartierville,
ce projet emballant est devenu
angoissant.
- Plus ça avance, plus je me
dis : "Ah, mon dieu, on va-tu
commencer un jour, là?"
- Ils attendent leur permis
pour commencer les travaux
depuis plus de trois mois.
Entre-temps, ils ont déjà libéré
leur maison et vivent
dans un appartement
avec leurs deux enfants.
CHRISTIAN PEPIN, propriétaire,
Ahuntsic-Cartierville
- Évidemment, on est à double
frais, c'est certain qu'on paye
l'hypothèque ici, on paye
le logement là-bas.
JUDITH FARRELL, propriétaire,
Ahuntsic-Cartierville
- On va-tu l'avoir, le permis,
on va-tu pas l'avoir?
Quand est-ce que les travaux
commencent? L'hiver s'en vient,
est-ce que l'entrepreneur
va être disponible
quand on va avoir le permis?
- Depuis 2019, les délais
pour obtenir des permis
de construction, de rénovation
et de transformation ont explosé
dans plusieurs arrondissements.
Ils sont passés de 44
à 68 jours en moyenne
dans Ahuntsic-Cartierville,
de 29 à 73 jours dans
Mercier-Hochelaga-Maisonneuve,
de 44 à 85 jours sur le
Plateau-Mont-Royal et de 55
à 116 jours dans Ville-Marie.
Sur le Plateau, les demandes
de permis ont chuté
pendant les premiers mois
de la pandémie, et puis en juin
2020, ce fut le déluge.
- Ça, ça a créé un embouteillage
des demandes.
- L'arrondissement est toujours
en train de rattraper ce retard,
alors qu'il peine à recruter
des agents pour traiter
les demandes
LUC RABOUIN,
maire du Plateau-Mont-Royal
- L'industrie s'arrache
les personnes qui ont
des compétences techniques.
Donc, nous, on a perdu
des employés. On en a recruté
de nouveau, il faut les former,
ça prend un certain temps
avant qu'ils soient efficaces.
- À Rosemont, les délais
de traitement sont stables
depuis quatre ans : entre
27 et 30 jours en moyenne.
L'arrondissement, qui était
l'un des cancres en la matière,
a revu ses processus
et est devenu premier de classe.
FRANÇOIS WILLIAM CROTEAU,
maire de Rosemont-La-Petite-Pat.
- Avant, il y avait plusieurs
étapes de validation
de l'information qui étaient
parfois inutiles, redondantes,
il y avait aussi le fait que
plusieurs personnes pouvaient
s'échanger le même dossier.
Maintenant, il y a un seul agent
qui s'occupe d'un dossier.
- La situation complique aussi
la vie des entrepreneurs, qui
doivent planifier les travaux
et commander les matériaux.
RAMZE RAAD, président,
Rénovation Raco
- Si on n'a pas le permis,
on ne peut pas passer
les commandes. Si ça continue
comme ça, est-ce que le monde va
commencer à négliger les permis?
Ça, c'est une question à poser.
- C'est justement ce que
décident de faire certains
clients de cette designer
d'intérieur.
FRÉDÉRIQUE CROZE, designer
d'intérieur, propriét. Zü Design
- Nous, on ne les encourage pas
à faire ça, mais ça arrive
parce qu'à un moment donné, on
ne peut plus attendre, en fait.
- Une idée qui est aussi passée
par la tête de Judith Farrell.
- Je commencerais les travaux
sans permis. Je ne le ferai pas
là, mais pour vous dire à quel
point je suis exaspérée.
- Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.